يُطلق عليهم اسم شباب التلال في
مقطع فيديو تم تصويره الأسبوع الماضي نشرته
مجموعة إسرائيلية لحقوق الإنسان
يظهرون وهم ينزلون عبر بساتين الزيتون
ويهاجمون مزارعين فلسطينيين متطرفين
مستوطنين إسرائيليين يأتون كل عام
ويقولون إنهم يعطّلون الحصاد الفلسطيني
كل عام الحاخام ماشا  متطوعو ياهودي
كدرع بشري
للمزارعين ولكن إيمانه هذا العام
لم يقدم أي حماية كانوا يعرفون أنني
يهودي وكانوا يعرفون أنني أساعد هؤلاء
الفلسطينيين ، لذلك بالنسبة لهم لا
شيء أسوأ من هذا لأنهم
يرون  الفلسطينيون عند الأعداء
يقول الحاخام إن رجال ملثمين أحاطوا به
ضربوه بقضيب حديدي وكسروا
ذراعه كثيرًا من المال هل وودي أنا
أبلغ من العمر 80 عامًا قلت لهم أن يتركوني
وشأنه يبكي ذراعي تؤلمني كثيرًا لذا إنه أمر
مذهل حقًا  بالنسبة لي مدى قرب
المستوطنات والبؤر الاستيطانية
من القرى الفلسطينية التي
نتجه إليها إلى يوتا حيث نادرًا ما يسمحون
للغرباء بالدخول إلى المستوطنة
لقد قام شباب التلال
بمضايقة المزارعين الفلسطينيين لسنوات
حتى أنهم أحرقوا بساتينهم عندما
هاجموا مؤخرًا الجيش الإسرائيلي
وضابطًا كبيرًا كانت خطوة بعيدة جدًا
تثير الإدانة من المستوطنين مثل
سوكوت الذي وصفها بالغضب وحتى
رئيس الوزراء الإسرائيلي
قائد إسرائيلي  أغلق هذه المناطق
لمحاولة الحفاظ على السلام ،
لقد أدان الجيش الإسرائيلي هذا النوع من العنف ،
هل تأخذهم على محمل الجد في تلك
الإدانة اليوم وللأسف إذا
كنت مواطنًا إسرائيليًا وأنت
تنتهك حقوق الفلسطينيين
، فستأخذ معجزة وهذا شيء
أنه سيتم محاكمتك وشيء ستوجه إليك لائحة اتهام ،
فلن يحدث لك شيء على ما
يرام ، ولكن الآن يجب على المزارعين الفلسطينيين مثل
موسى والشامي وشقيقته
التسلل إلى المناطق العسكرية المغلقة
المختبئين خلف أشجارهم فقط
لإنهاء  الحصاد نحن محاطون
بالمستوطنات ، كما يقول يسارًا ويمينًا ،
ترى المستوطنات التي ستراها اليوم المريخي  يوميات
عندما قام
المستوطنون بتمزيق أغصان مثل هذه
، يقول إنه يشعر وكأنهم
يمزقون ذراعي طفله ديفيد ماكنزي
سي إن إن الضفة الغربية